ah
el consejo de derechos humanos de la onu
aprobó por amplia mayoría iniciar una
investigación sobre los posibles
crímenes de guerra rusos en ucrania la
alta comisionada de la organización de
naciones unidas precisamente para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet se
refirió a este tema escuchemos la ofis
continuamos verificando denuncias de
violaciones al derecho internacional a
los derechos humanos y al derecho
internacional humanitario muchas de las
cuales pueden constituir crímenes de
guerra o war crimes whisky la escalada
de homicidios ilegítimos incluidos
indicios de ejecuciones sumarias en
áreas al norte de kiev es impactante si
bien tenemos información sobre 300 de
esos homicidios las cifras seguirán
aumentando a medida que se disponga de
nuevas provincias dejamos de bilbo
también destacado durante esta semana lo
que está sucediendo en suecia y en
finlandia países que podrían convertirse
oficialmente en integrantes de la otan
abandonar su neutralidad histórica ante
la amenaza que representa rusia para
ellos pero es el kremlin en moscú el que
ha dicho sentirse amenazado por esta
decisión de incorporarse a la alianza
atlántica moscú ha dicho que rusia se
verá obligada a tomar medidas de
represalia si se unen a la otan entonces
quien está amenazando a quien en días
anteriores también hubo fuertes combates
en el puerto de odessa que todavía no
cae por completo en las manos rusas
mientras que las fuerzas ucranianas han
recuperado localidades y zonas
circundantes a la ciudad de jarquín en
el noreste en una contraofensiva
mientras que los prorrusos en la ciudad
de gerson pidieron su anexión total a la
federación de rusia de otra parte siguen
también los esfuerzos europeos para
concretar el cese del fuego mientras que
eeuu envía más armamento al ejército
ucraniano pero no podemos olvidar a esos
cerca de 8 millones de desplazados
internos y también a los millones de
refugiados en países y la situación
humanitaria sigue siendo crítica en
ucrania veamos
el drama humanitario censarse band
ucrania en la semana 11 de hostilidades
y ataques indiscriminados del ejército
ruso naciones unidas dice que las
víctimas civiles superan por miles a las
más de siete mil reportadas por el
propio organismo entre heridos y
fallecidos en total hasta la fecha hemos
corroborado 7 mil 61 víctimas civiles
con tres mil 381 muertos y tres mil 680
heridos en todo el país desde el inicio
del ataque armado de la federación rusa
las cifras reales son mayores y estamos
trabajando para corroborar cada uno de
los incidentes
las cifras representan un agujero negro
especialmente en ciudades como mariupol
dado que los incesantes bombardeos del
kremlin impiden la entrada de los
organismos internacionales para
esclarecer las violaciones de derechos
humanos cometidas durante más de dos
meses de asedio según las autoridades
locales al menos 100 civiles continúan
atrapados en el último reducto de
resistencia ucraniana la acería de aces
tal y miles más en las inmediaciones de
la arrasada urbe
debemos de entender que en mariupol hay
más de 100 mil civiles que están
esperando que se les dé la oportunidad
de salir y que tengan no sólo el deseo
sino también la oportunidad de salvar
sus vidas por lo tanto instó a todos a
unirse y a no rendirse en esta situación
tan difícil
hospitales escuelas o teatros que son
refugio han sido atacados la
organización mundial de la salud
denunció la muerte de al menos tres mil
personas por falta de acceso a sus
tratamientos médicos almost hándicaps
con casi 200 ataques sanitarios
verificados y documentados por la oms s
sobre el terreno q crearía es testigo
del mayor y más rápido asalto al sistema
sanitario a su personal y a sus
pacientes and space y la emergencia
humanitaria se traduce también en el
número de desplazados internos más de 8
millones de ucranianos huyeron de sus
hogares para proteger sus vidas el 63
por ciento son mujeres y 6 millones han
salido del país más de 8 millones de
personas han sido desplazadas
internamente en ucrania necesitan
desesperadamente dinero en efectivo
medicinas y refugio por su parte moscú
continúa negando ataques a la población
civil y califica su invasión como una
operación militar especial a grandes
rasgos estos son los hechos más
recientes relacionados con el conflicto
en ucrania muchas aristas para analizar
entonces es posible
acción de suecia y finlandia a la otan
esto sería entonces un nuevo detonante
de inestabilidad en europa porque las
tropas rusas están avanzando lentamente
y sus logros son poco significativos
como entender entonces ese concepto de
guerra de desgaste ahora se abre también
el capítulo de los crímenes de guerra y
de lesa humanidad esto podrá entonces
generar más presión internacional sobre
el kremlin pero que hay de ucrania no
está exento de haber cometido también
estos crímenes contra los rusos y contra
los separatistas en el debate de france
24 vamos a analizar los hechos más
recientes en torno a la guerra en
ucrania para analizar este tema
saludamos a erika ruiz sandoval ella es
internacionalista profesora visitante
del centro de investigación y docencia
económicas cide ella se encuentra en la
ciudad de mexico y desde san jose en
costa rica se conecta a esta
conversación francisco barahona él es
politólogo y abogado internacionalista
también es director de la maestría de
derechos humanos en la universidad de
costa rica ustedes nuestros televidentes
también pueden participar en este debate
con todos sus comentarios y preguntas lo
pueden a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24
s
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal de
recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es numeral del
debate efe 24 esperamos por supuesto
todos sus comentarios y preguntas
comienzo entonces con erika dándole la
bienvenida ella se conecta desde la
ciudad de mexico erika gracias por estar
con nosotros aquí en el debate y un
punto de partida para este programa
quiero comenzarlo con los hechos
recientes en torno al consejo de
derechos humanos de la onu que aprobó
por amplia mayoría inicial esa
investigación por presuntos crímenes de
guerra por parte de las tropas rusas ya
han dicho que tienen pruebas suficientes
para demostrar algunos casos
así es definitivamente uno de los rasgos
de esta nueva guerra que tenemos en el
panorama internacional es la evidencia
que se puede ver que se puede palpar
gracias a la existencia de nuevos medios
de comunicación redes sociales y demás
sobre los crímenes cometidos por las
tropas rusas y como habían apuntado a
usted quizás también por tropas
ucranianas
creo que la diferencia en este caso
estará en que la evidencia se está
recogiendo en el momento en que ocurren
y esto puede hacer una gran diferencia a
la hora de someter a los responsables a
los juicios correspondientes de todas
formas no será fácil sentar en el
banquillo de los acusados a los
responsables porque evidentemente se
presta a todo tipo de interpretaciones y
será un proceso largo doloroso pero
necesario porque de otra manera
seguiremos viendo este tipo de acciones
en el sistema internacional y le doy
también la bienvenida francisco barahona
en la ciudad de san josé en costa rica
también francisco como punto de partida
esta pregunta sobre estas
investigaciones sobre presuntos
de guerra crímenes de lesa humanidad
tanto del lado ruso en este momento solo
que de hecho la onu pero no se puede
descartar también que las tropas
ucranianas hayan cometido algunos hechos
similares contra las tropas rusas y
contra los separatistas
comenzamos por el lado ruso un país que
dependiendo de la situación en la que se
encuentre es garante uno de los acuerdos
internacionales que tanto puede
responder entonces rusia a estas
acusaciones en el marco de esta guerra
bueno puede responder más bien frente a
naciones unidas a partir de la decisión
que ustedes comentaban del consejo de
derechos humanos de naciones unidas pero
hay que recordar que la federación rusa
no es parte del conjunto
internacional de orientadores y defensor
de la doctrina de los derechos humanos
especialmente en todo lo que tiene que
ver con crímenes de guerra y creo que
eso es un gran defecto del sistema
mundial de las naciones unidas- puesto
que tampoco los eeuu ha ratificado las
convenciones respectivas pero aún así
toda esta investigación el fruto de la
realidad que estamos viendo día a día de
una guerra violatoria del derecho
internacional y además
lanzada esta invasión a partir de un
conjunto de mentiras y declaraciones de
parte de las autoridades rusas
inclusive incluyendo a su presidente el
presidente putin días antes semanas
antes negaban que la acumulación de
tropas en la frontera con ucrania y
rusia está orientada más bien a juegos
de guerra a prácticas militares sino de
camino a una invasión y a pesar de
haberlo negado incluyendo unos dos días
antes después hubo un pequeño silencio
de 24 horas y se lanzó lo que ellos
llaman la operación especial pero que no
es sino otra cosa que efectivamente una
invasión al territorio y a la soberanía
de un estado y entonces lo que vemos más
bien es que hay una valoración violación
flagrante de la carta de la organización
de las naciones unidas
renuncia de parte de rusia a tratar de
encontrar una salida negociada pacífica
a los conflictos y a los razonamientos
que el kremlin ha estado haciendo para
justificar su guerra entonces bueno creo
que sería muy interesante
si la óptica desde la óptica del derecho
internacional en la alta comisionada
puede llegar y la comisión a establecer
efectivamente de frente a estos crímenes
y especialmente de rusia
a la guerra si francis que sean que se
han producido y llegar a alguna alguna
sanción tipo personal por los
responsables que han dado estas órdenes
haro de los que han ejecutado las
órdenes y por supuesto la
responsabilidad del estado ruso en esa
directiva pero bueno queda mucha agua
por delante porque no agrada a nuestros
anteriores para poder estar midiendo hoy
en día
cuando jurídicamente lo que estamos
analizando erika le pregunto por el otro
lado de la moneda todavía no se habla de
crímenes por parte de ucrania pero en un
conflicto como éste para las partes que
están involucradas algunas veces todo
vale no y no hay una investigación en
curso por parte de autoridades o de
organismos internacionales para ver el
lado de ucrania y ucrania cuenta con el
apoyo de buena parte de la comunidad
internacional en este conflicto pero
cómo quedaría ucrania si se da inicio a
una investigación en donde pueda verse
que pronto el ejército y sus tropas
están involucrados también en crímenes
de guerra y de lesa humanidad
pero creo que ucrania vaya a perder el
capital político que ha ganado con esta
guerra con esta invasión como bien decía
el profesor es claramente una violación
al derecho internacional
y me parece que dado que ucrania es la
víctima de esta agresión es a quien le
han violado la soberanía y la integridad
territorial
creo que la opinión pública
internacional no juzgará de manera
distinta en caso de que se revelara
alguna falta por parte de tropas
premiadas probablemente exijan justicia
también pero en todo caso es evidente
quién es el agresor en este caso además
con un poderío que se supone es
infinitamente superior al al ucraniano
sin razón aparente sin sin causa de
guerra realmente entonces creo que a
pesar de que se llevaron a cabo
investigaciones que revelaron algún tipo
de falta en este sentido por parte de
los combatientes ucranianos creo que
el juicio será distinto con respecto al
al juicio que se hará sobre las tropas
rusas además que estaba un poco en
sintonía también con la fiscalía
ucraniana que también anunció la
apertura del primer caso contra un
soldado ruso por un presunto crimen de
guerra estaba un poco en sintonía con
estos organismos internacionales esto
apenas está comenzando y va a tener
desarrollo en las próximas semanas ya
veremos cuál es el desenlace de esta
primera investigación por parte de la
fiscalía ucraniana en kiev paso al
siguiente punto de la agenda tenemos
muchos temas para analizar en el
programa de hoy quiero preguntarle a
francisco por la situación esa atención
que se está viviendo con suecia
finlandia y rusia por esa posible
incorporación a la otan a abandonar
cerca de ocho décadas de neutralidad por
lo menos en el caso de finlandia un país
que además en el pasado ya vivió una
posición similar a la que tiene ucrania
cuando en el 39 la unión soviética
invadió finlandia y desató la guerra de
invierno
es esto otro punto detonante para más
inestabilidad en europa es esto darle
más argumentos a rusia para atacar otros
territorios o para seguir mostrándole
digamos los dientes a occidente y su
capacidad militar
miren los fantasmas del imperialismo
ruso históricamente hablando
obviamente tienen que ser
aquilatados en términos de la realidad
que estamos viviendo y además recordando
la historia esos países que usted acaba
de mencionar fueron parte de la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviéticas y la
apuesta que esos países han hecho una
vez que cayó el muro de berlín y se
disolvió la unión de repúblicas
soviéticas les permitió tener un camino
de acercamiento
a la unión europea y también a la otan
pero manteniendo la bandera de una
supuesta neutralidad frente al hecho
militar y como como esa sorpresa la
actitud de rusia de la federación rusa
con esta invasión pues obviamente esto
obliga a los estrategas de la política
internacional de esos países siendo
países pequeños en comparación con el
poderío militar de la federación rusa a
tener que recurrir a la alianza
atlántica que es la única fuerza militar
del presente es organizada y pactada
justamente para equilibrar el poderío
del poderosos y el problema el problema
sea en bueno cómo va a reaccionar de
rusia a una toma de posición y a una
adhesión de estos dos hay más países que
lo pueden hacer de polonia y que ya es
parte de la otan pero
nadie quiere una guerra generalizada una
tercera guerra mundial en territorio y
el suelo europeo si el problema está en
que hay una gran incógnita hasta dónde
va a llegar útil que claramente es el
hombre que toma las decisiones de guerra
o paz
en la federación rusa hasta donde su
ciudadanía le va a permitir mantener lo
que lo que él llama a la exigencia a
francis concluyó de mantener la
soberanía rusa como elemento principal
incluyendo acciones de supuesta regular
de comillas defensa de su soberanía
entonces aquí hay un problema de
estrategia donde no solo están esos dos
países por su propia discusión sino a
todo el conjunto de la otan y por
supuesto la unión europea en juego y
además no nos olvidemos que hay armas
así francisco y hay una advertencia del
presidente putin de que los puede poner
en movimiento
eric a su opinión sobre este punto
importante la incorporación de suecia y
finlandia a la otan algo que puede
suceder en los próximos días
llama mucho la atención el caso de
finlandia y algunos análisis dicen que
suecia estaría esperando que helsinki dé
el primer paso porque de esa forma
helsinki o bueno finlandia podría
convertirse en un país colchón para
suecia poner como un territorio de por
medio e incorporado a la otan entre
rusia y el territorio sueco y eso
dejaría simplemente a suecia como un
país neutral que podría apoyar a
finlandia como lo ha hecho en el pasado
en conflictos a lo largo de la historia
pero pero que como que el que lanzarían
al vacío sería finlandia que es el país
vecino con una frontera de 1300
kilómetros en común con rusia
a ver este es el típico caso de dilema
de seguridad estudiamos en relaciones
internacionales mientras un país intenta
sentirse más seguro lo que hace es
generar inseguridad en el vecino y una
vez que el vecino se siente inseguro
también trata de aumentar su poder o de
unirse a alguna alianza y eso le vuelve
a provocar inseguridad al primero y es
un bucle interminable creo que en este
caso la lectura de finlandia y suecia es
que no tienen otra opción realmente ante
la agresividad rusa la sinrazón de esta
invasión la incapacidad para sentarse a
conversar
y la sordera total ante las solicitudes
de un cese del fuego creo que por eso ha
habido este cambio dramático en las
opiniones públicas de estos dos países
otra hora neutrales para decir sí sí
queremos que el país se incorpore a una
alianza militar en este caso la otan
creo que esto también abre la puerta a
una nueva era en términos de la
geopolítica internacional pero que en
ese sentido la lectura de finlandia y
suecia es este es el nuevo juego y para
este nuevo juego necesitamos este tipo
de herramienta lo curioso del caso es
que sea finlandia quien va primero quien
habitualmente sigue a suecia en este
tipo de decisiones es cierto que suecia
podría esperar un poco para ver si la
incorporación de finlandia la otan es
suficiente para tener una suerte de
barrera de colchón de si usted frente a
cualquier ataque ruso pero creo que que
dada la magnitud de lo acaecido en
ucrania
más le valdría a suecia también tramitar
su adhesión a la otan lo más pronto
posible
américa continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa seguimos con este
tema importante aclararon los puntos
suecia y finlandia pueden ser países
pequeños en población
pero ambos tienen ejércitos muy bien
equipados muy bien entrenados finlandia
no hace parte de la otan pero ha
colaborado con la otan en misiones
puntuales suecia es un país que ha
desarrollado muchísima tecnología
militar entonces son países bien
preparados y además son países de la
unión europea hablando de esas
repercusiones como lo calificaron desde
monte moscú de qué tipo de repercusiones
podríamos estar hablando cómo se podría
enfrentar a rusia a estos dos países
sabían lo que son militarmente
superiores por lo menos en tecnología en
ciertas
campos y dos que son países de la unión
europea
creo que que esta primera amenaza rusa
es simplemente insistir sobre el mismo
punto a rusia lo que le molesta es la
existencia de la otan y su ampliación
pero finalmente si si la otan sigue
existiendo y se sigue ampliándose en
buena medida por la amenaza que
representa rusia entonces
no no creo que pueda tomar medidas
particulares contra finlandia o contra
suecia una vez incorporados en la otan
porque eso implicaría definitivamente
declararle la guerra a la alianza
completa que no nos olvidemos incluye no
solamente este par de estados pequeños
pero bien armados sino también a la
primera potencia militar del mundo que
es estados unidos entonces ahí la jugada
de rusia tiene que ser muy cautelosa han
hecho algunos escarceos tratando de
lanzar misiles muy cerca de la frontera
con territorio de la otan es simplemente
para probar para intimidar pero si sería
un error garrafal
intentar hacer algo en contra de estos
dos países en caso de que ya fueran
miembros de derecho de la otan
lo interesante es que su adhesión a la
otan va a poder ser muy rápida justo por
lo que usted decía tienen ejércitos
modernos con muy buena muy buen equipo
un equipo muy moderno y además que tiene
interoperabilidad con los equipos de la
otan entonces aquí no no va a pasar
mucho tiempo para que en caso de que
tomen la decisión final esto se produce
claro lo que sí es cierto es que tal vez
estos reclamos de moscú y estas amenazas
de moscú lo que ha hecho es acercarle
mucho más la frontera de la otan a las
fronteras rusas con base en todos estos
reclamos que hace el kremlin en lo que
ha logrado es simplemente que más países
se muestren interesados entonces ahí
entró en el dilema de quien se está
acercando si la otan se está moviendo
hacia el este o si el este se está
moviendo hacia la otan para poderse
defender de rúsia paso a otro de los
temas importantes de la semana y son los
hechos que han tenido lugar en la ciudad
de kharkiv que es la ciudad la segunda
ciudad más grande de ucrania importante
destacar que allí las tropas ucranianas
han logrado recapturar algunas
poblaciones algunas aldeas y zonas
cercanas a esta ciudad y ha habido
intensos combates allí francisco voy con
usted que representa volver a empezar a
acercarse a jarquín para las tropas
ucranianas y como entender ese juego del
ejército ruso de esta guerra de desgaste
una guerra lenta de espacios a que no
tiene mayores conquistas para mostrar
pero que es como una gran piedra en el
camino para los ucranianos
y bueno yo le diría que los ucraniano no
están solos no sólo en la opinión
pública internacional sino están siendo
apoyados fuertemente con recursos
militares recursos económicos y
probablemente inteligencia militar esto
significa que cuando uno escuchan las
noticias que parte del ejército
ucraniano ha retomado reconquista
algunas aldeas
algunas partes de ciudades importantes
ucranianas pues si la gloria se la
llevan esos luchadores pero en el fondo
lo que estamos presenciando es el inicio
de una posible guerra que sólo tiene dos
salidas pero yo no veo una salida por el
momento de negociación pese a que esa
vía es la vía normal para países
neutrales y sobre todo para países como
como el mío costa rica que tiene una
apuesta con la neutralidad y además es
un país desarmado desmilitarizado y sin
ejército pero la realidad entraña en
este momento y la conquista de los
territorios ligados al este y al mar al
mar negro de ucrania por tropas rusas me
pareciera que no lo veo en el ganar una
ni una solución negociada ni una
solución rápida
me da la impresión de que esto va a ser
un proceso de varios son de varios meses
para no decir más periodo largo de lucha
de pelea de confrontación humana de de
destrozos humanos y materiales terribles
según las cámaras son testigos que todos
los días nos vemos pero además una
confrontación con los jefes una de las
cosas importantes que ha sucedido a
través de la invasión rusa y no de la
operación especial como dice el
presidente ruso es que bueno revitalizó
completamente la importancia estratégica
táctica y militar de la otan es la que
aparece frente a las acciones de
invasión y de violación de la soberanía
de ucrania parte de rusia como el
tajamar como la muralla que protege al
resto de europa y que protege al resto
de los países democráticos y por
supuesto registrarse engañado principal
y de mayor poder militar que los eeuu
entonces si francisco 11 a veces se
pierden el detalle de cómo está el
ajedrez de las que funcionan las tropas
cuántos tanques han
destruido 600 650 tanques barcos
hundidos etcétera etcétera pero en el
fondo lo que está pasando es mucho más
graves y francisco realmente es
realmente una una enfermedad psicológica
que produce la guerra le pido por favor
que responda un poco más puntual porque
me quedan ya pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa y tengo más temas
para analizar por favor un poco más
corta en sus respuestas para poder
abarcar diferentes temas son puntos
importantes los que usted toca claro que
sí pero debo abarcar también otros temas
destacados de la semana
erika hablemos de ese punto que estaba
mencionando francisco que ésta puede ser
una una guerra de largo aliento muy
lenta pero pero puede llevar mucho más
tiempo de lo que se está esperando y que
no haya una mesa de negociación por lo
menos es lo que está buscando el
canciller alemán olaf scholz y el
presidente francés emmanuel marco
después de ese encuentro que tuvieron en
berlín para tratar de
y buscar mecanismos para abrir una mesa
de diálogo para buscar salidas a este
conflicto
a ver este conflicto en parte el
problema está en que estamos ya en el
plan b es decir este definitivamente no
era el plan a de rusia que pensaban
arrasar a ucrania en 72 horas
básicamente lo cual fue una muy mala
planeación de su operación no especial
entre muchas comillas entonces
definitivamente por eso también estamos
viendo la crudeza de esta de esta guerra
estamos viendo estos ataques a la
población civil con el fin de desesperar
a ucrania pero creo que ucrania
ha logrado primero echarse en el
bolsillo a la opinión pública mundial
prácticamente en su totalidad y las
excepciones son importantes pero también
tener el respaldo significativo de
occidente es decir de europa y de eeuu
creo que a partir de aquí las en la
estatura internacional de ucrania va a
ser muy distinta sin importar cuánto
cuanto dure esta guerra ahora sí es
importante pensar en qué tipo de final
se puede dar a esto porque
definitivamente por ahora lo que tenemos
es la humillación de rusia es decir el
supuesto octavo ejército en el mundo no
está pudiendo con ucrania e incluso con
los refuerzos que pueden mandar
eeuu o que pueden mandar los países
europeos entonces hay que dar una salida
a putin hay que dar una salida que le
permita medianamente salvar cara si
queremos que esto termine pronto
erika eeuu sostuvo lo voy a conocer esta
semana que moscú pretende asegurar las
zonas ucranianas a lo largo de la costa
del mar negro ya desde las costas del
mar de azov para asegurar un corredor
hasta hasta moldavia esto implicaría que
cayera la ciudad de odessa este puerto
importante ucraniano en el mar negro que
todavía sigue dando la batalla ya hay
zonas que han sido conquistadas por los
rusos pero la ciudad no ha sido
capturada por completo por las tropas de
la federación esto que significaría
sería parte de ese movimiento hacia el
este de ucrania sería tal vez dar un
paso hacia moldavia y transnistria cuál
es el análisis que usted hace
pues que de verdad estamos en el plan cl
o a saber qué planes ya para para rusia
y es difícil del otro lado saber con qué
se conformaría rusia es decir qué es lo
que está buscando qué es lo que quiere
este corredor quiere los territorios
ruso fornos de ucrania quiere las partes
separatistas con que aunque porque
quedaría satisfecho y yo creo que en esa
respuesta está la clave de cuándo va a
terminar el conflicto y cómo va a
terminar este conflicto es cierto que se
empieza a amenazar a otros países desde
luego moldavia y esto también pone en
alerta a
europa desde luego que tiene que tomar
decisiones sobre
sí y extender la mano también a otros
territorios se trata de georgia se trata
de moldavia simplemente para protegerlos
no nos podemos olvidar de que la unión
europea es una comunidad de seguridad a
pesar de que no tenga poderío militar y
esta es una de las grandes discusiones
que esta invasión ha desatado en el seno
de la unión europea no deja de ser una
comunidad de seguridad para país es esta
zona entonces ahí vamos a ver en qué
termina la película es terrible
francisco dentro de este corredor que
estoy mencionando que va a lo largo de
la costa está la región de gerzón que
tengo una en la capital homónima la
ciudad de gerzón donde las autoridades o
parte de las personas que todavía están
allí controlando la la zona son pre
rusos y han pedido al kremlin su pronta
incorporación a la federación como
entiende uno que territorios al interior
de ucrania le apuesten a pertenecer a
rusia y no tratar de defender la
independencia y la integridad
territorial ucraniana
y mire como lo mencionó la profesora
erika esta película tiene ya muchos años
comenzó hace ocho años un poquito más
con la invasión
justamente de crimea y lo mismo que
sucedió con la invasión de criminales
que sí fue digamos más rápida más fácil
para la integración rusa contando con
una población
rusoparlante y muchos ciudadanos rusos
pues se organizó un referéndum de mala
manera muy rápido para pedir que rusia
reconociera esos territorios como parte
integral del territorio ruso bueno el
mismo libreto está siendo llevado a cabo
por rusia en el caso que usted nos acaba
de exponer pareciera que esa es un poco
la lógica y ese es el problema que
profundiza más la guerra porque ucrania
nunca aceptó que segregará rusia crimea
y bueno la polarización
desde hace 8 años donde se produjo esa
invasión militar
bueno no ha cesado sino en preparación
para lo que estamos viviendo hoy en día
así que independientemente de que el
libreto sea parecido como usted lo acaba
de mencionar que haya ciudadanos rusos o
de origen ruso puede hablar rusa que
comiencen ya a organizar una especie de
referéndum entre comillas popular para
que rusia para pedirle a rusia que los
incorpore como territorio ruso y aunque
rusa lo haga rusia lo haga la comunidad
nacional no sólo el gobierno ucraniano
la comunidad internacional naciones
unidas no lo puede aceptar porque eso
significa darle luz verde
la república rusa para hacer algo
parecido con
cualquiera de los países ex del imperio
soviético y entonces bueno estamos
hablando de finlandia electrónica
estonia y no sólo de moldavia o de
georgia que que acabamos de tener una
referencia entonces es muy difícil que
esta invasión rusa se pueda digamos
galvanizar una nueva situación
internacional dándole un triunfo o un
triunfo a una operación militar
totalmente ilegal anti humana
y en esto quiero recordar un poco las
palabras del papa francisco que no sólo
está pidiendo diálogo y búsqueda de
zonas como un acuerdo de concordia pase
hacia el futuro sino que está dando una
lucha también contra la
desmilitarización en el mundo gracias el
segundo fenómeno que estamos viendo que
está surgiendo de lo que estamos
analizando cada vez hay más carrera al
momento y si esto sigue así la situación
va a ser mucho más peligrosa para todo
europa y para el resto del planeta claro
erika para finalizar y ya aproximándonos
al fin del programa quiero hablar de el
9 de mayo el día de la victoria un día
que desde occidente se esperaba que
rusia hiciera muchos anuncios hubo
muchísima especulación en los medios de
comunicación sobre lo que rusia podría
anunciar en ese día en cuanto a
victorias en cuanto a pasos a seguir en
este conflicto y rusia no dijo
absolutamente nada de declarar o
reconocer la independencia de donets o
lugansk incorporar gerson o pasar de
calificar este conflicto como una
intervención militar a llamarlo ya
abiertamente guerra moscú simplemente no
dijo nada parte de la estrategia aparte
de la histeria de occidente como lo ha
calificado el presidente putin cuál es
su análisis
creo que rusia está haciendo los planes
sobre las rodillas y sobre la marcha en
ese sentido lo que se esperaba para el 9
de mayo que era esto de declarar ya una
guerra formal o de reconocer victorias
etcétera simple y llanamente no no
consiguió los suficientes evidencias o
los suficientes triunfos para hacerlo
así de todas formas el 9 de mayo le
sirve a putin para volver a agitar el
nacionalismo ruso para tratar de
justificar lo que está haciendo en
ucrania que finalmente sí como como dice
el profesor es parece que es la secuela
no desde lo que pasó con un crack un
primer perdón pero creo que esta vez el
occidente aprendió la lección y por eso
esta vez no se limita a las sanciones
económicas sino también a fortalecer a
ucrania y ayudarla a defenderse y ser
mucho más vocal en el rechazo a las
acciones militares tratar de utilizar
también los foros existentes naciones
unidas así que creo que en esta ocasión
podemos esperar un final diferente
no se va no creo que el rusia puedan
salirse de la suya y comerse el
territorio nada más erika francisco me
queda un minuto para finalizar el
programa conclusiones lo que podemos ver
en las próximas semanas más ataques más
confrontación de pronto una mesa de
diálogo más posicionamiento de la unión
europea y eeuu
la incorporación de suecia y finlandia
francisco muy puntual por favor todo lo
que usted acaba de mencionar es una
realidad y está dentro del calendario no
voy a utilizar segundos para
multiplicar lo que usted muy claramente
ha establecido son las hipótesis de
trabajo que tenemos todos los que nos
informamos de estos temas pero lo grave
por un lado es la pérdida de vidas la
pérdida material inclusive de edificios
históricos
a mí no me extrañaría que si la guerra
se continúa no pudiera ver también
acciones militares en territorio ruso
claro parte de parte de ucrania así que
bueno la situación hay que monitorear la
muy de cerca y yo espero que la
comunidad internacional naciones unidas
el cruce de donaciones sean derechos
humanos no tarden mucho tiempo en poder
llegar a conclusiones concretas de
violación de derechos y francisco
flagrante se estima 30 segundos para la
constitución francisco perdón lo tengo
que cortar porque me quedan 30 segundos
erika por favor su conclusión a traer
esto también es una guerra de nervios la
guerra de paciencia es una guerra de
anticipar lo que va a ser el otro en ese
sentido si los costos humanos seguirán
subiendo mientras no se pueda tomar otra
medida y será una cuestión de ver qué
tanto resiste el frente que apoya a
ucrania
tremblay a todos los costos que esto
está teniendo y no nos olvidemos de las
consecuencias de largo plazo estos
desplazados estos muertos después
influirán en como componemos la historia
después claro dejarán
francisco muchas gracias por este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales y por supuesto sigan viendo
france24
[Música]